what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu and today marvel studios
dropped the miss marvel teaser trailer
on us out of nowhere now typically i'm
aware of the trailers before they're
going to drop at least a couple of days
before at the very least but it looks
like marvel studios is trying to be a
little bit sneaky now because this took
everybody by surprise now i'm traveling
right now so i don't have my normal
setup so i'm going to give you my
initial reaction right now and also do
the trailer breakdown i don't have any
camera set up with me right now to do a
live reaction to the trailer but things
should be back to normal next week so
right off the bat just a few thoughts
initially about the trailer and we'll
dive right into the breakdown after this
is definitely a show that they're trying
to use to appeal to younger audiences
it's definitely a different type of show
than they've done before i think so far
with the disney plus shows for marvel
they've all kind of had the same feel
even what if pretty much had the same
feel as the other shows now of course
they are about different things but for
the most part they have that marvel feel
and this does too but it kind of takes
it up a notch adding to the comic e feel
of this now the trailer is really cool
how they do all the pop-ups it looks
really cartoony it's kind of like her
journal is coming to life in the trailer
i'm not sure if this is actually going
to be in the actual series i think they
may just be doing this for the trailer
but either way it's really cool for a
first official teaser and again it is
kind of appealing to that younger
audience also i love blinded by the
light by the weekend it made for a
perfect feel for this trailer and what i
really like actually about this trailer
is that they're kind of giving us a look
at what it's like in this universe for
somebody who doesn't actually have
powers but idolizes these people with
superpowers in a way it's kind of like
us right now all of us nerds who love
superheroes and wish we could be them
but superheroes actually exist in this
universe and i don't know if that would
be worse or better like dang they're
actually real i actually could be one
but i'm not sad now it shows her in a
meeting with who i assume as a guidance
counselor talking about how her grades
are kind of slipping because she's
daydreaming all of the time about being
a superhero about being prom queen kind
of typical teenage stuff you know until
she stumbles upon a pair of bands is
what i'm going to call them and we'll
talk about these because i do believe
that these are in fact the nega bands
and i believe that they do have a really
strong connection to the fantastic four
and i think there's a lot going on with
them here in this teaser trailer and
miss marvel in general and of course the
marvels that is coming with captain
marvel and monica rambo but they
completely changed kamala khan's powers
and let's talk about that right now but
really quick did you notice they gave us
an official release date for miss marvel
at the very end it says miss marvel
original series streaming june 8th which
is crazy because i actually called this
because i heard we were getting this
trailer before thor love and thunder and
i thought this was going to come out
before so i said hey it's probably
coming out in june here we are now this
will overlap with obi-wan kenobi a
little bit for you star wars fans and
marvel is starting to produce a lot of
content now so it's really awesome for
us fans to have so much going on right
now now back to kamala khan's powers and
they do make it a point to show us that
it is kamala khan
kamala another adventure shirt cute and
obviously we have the biggest
confirmation in this trailer that we've
all been waiting for mephisto confirmed
100 right here now kamala's powers in
this teaser trailer are a lot different
than they are in the comics in the
comics kamala khan gets exposed to
terrigen mist and this activates her
inhuman gene which gives her powers now
clearly they have changed this which is
very interesting because miss marvel was
actually a pretty popular comic when
kamala's inhuman powers get activated
she gets morphogenic abilities she can
extend and enlarge her limbs and her
body now we kind of see this in the
trailer but not in the typical way that
we've seen in the comics this kind of
looks like an extension of energy and it
looks like she has to use these bands
that she finds in her attic now it's
very clear based on what we've seen in
this trailer that these bands actually
give her her powers she is not exposed
to anything and it looks like marvel
really is kind of stepping away from the
inhumans in the mcu we thought that this
might be how they come in but it looks
like they are going a completely
different direction so kamala gets her
powers from these bands and it looks
like based off of what she said it gives
her the ability to somewhat control some
cosmic energy now as i mentioned before
to me these kind of look like a fresh
take on the nega bands i also thought
quasar immediately and thought these
could be the quantum bands but they
definitely seem to be more of the nega
bands especially because the nega bands
can be linked back to the cree and
considering that miss marvel is going to
be in the marvels and we assume that the
cree are going to be a part of that
movie as well that makes more sense plus
the powers that the mega bands would
give miss marvel seem to be on point
with what we see here in this trailer
now the mega bands are a powerful cree
relic that have been around for a
millennia and what they do is transform
mental energy into physical energy which
is definitely what seems like is going
on in this trailer now here's where
things kind of get interesting in the
comics the nega bands were awarded to
captain marvel they were awarded to him
by the cree supreme intelligence however
they quickly trapped him in the negative
zone and if you look at this very
specific scene in the trailer it looks
like kamala at one point in time goes to
a different dimension it looks like
she's at a school dance and then all of
a sudden she flips over backwards she's
still at the school dance but it looks
like she's in somewhat of a different
dimension here and this could actually
be the negative zone now this is really
exciting because the negative zone has
huge implications for the fantastic four
we know a fantastic four movie is
already in development at marvel studios
right now we know it's not that far away
and if this truly is the negative zone
could this be a setup for the fantastic
four to eventually make their way to the
mcu hopefully that is the case and i'll
do a breakdown of just the fantastic
four and the negative zone a little bit
later on but keeping to kamal khan
what's very interesting is that it only
seems to be one bracelet here in the
trailer and kamala khan actually does
wear a bracelet in the comics now this
bracelet gives her no powers whatsoever
it's simply an heirloom passed down to
her from her grandma and she just simply
likes to wear the bracelet because what
it means to her and it looks like
they're kind of doing a play off that in
this show but that kind of makes you
think do any of her ancestors have
powers where any of her ancestors
superheroes before now kamala khan is a
pakistani american growing up in jersey
city and as you can tell from the
trailer she idolizes superheroes
specifically captain marvel we see her
wearing a shirt in the very beginning
captain marvel is right there in the
beginning to her left is the wasp and to
the right it definitely looks like
valkyrie here i'm gonna go ahead and say
that's who it is but again keep in mind
kamala khan miss marvel is going to be
in the marvels so how exactly is this
connection made well if this really is a
version of the nega bands that she's
wearing on her wrist that gives her her
powers it would make sense because it's
a cree relic the marvels is captain
marvel number two and the first captain
marvel film explored the war between the
cree and the skrull and kind of made the
cree out to be bad guys here so if
kamala khan has stumbled upon some
ancient cree powerful relic that's
probably going to put her in some type
of trouble and it's definitely going to
attract the attention of captain marvel
whether that she has to defend kamala
khan from cree or maybe the bands
actually only can bond to one user at a
time and they're stuck with kamala khan
so she actually recruits her to help
we'll have to wait and see but in the
meantime let me know what you thought
about this very first trailer teaser
trailer for miss marvel coming to disney
plus on june 8th did you like it did you
not like it are you going to watch it
let me know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel news for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you